hey we are back on the game sweat stage
sponsored by air heads and toys are
happening again because yeah is this is
the first time I've hosted a gamespot
III stage and and it's just toys they're
just stirring toys at me so I'm like
yeah that's fine that's good that works
out ah we've seen lego dimensions which
is such an amazing game and I'm so
excited and we have a whole set wait for
the lower third to go away go away um no
no actually rewritten lovely people's
names because we've got otha and we've
got Jason here hello and um it's it's
very exciting you guys excited to be
here yeah you're are you enjoying your
yes me it's been a great show so far
right yeah awesome no that's fantastic
and you've brought so many things yeah
look at what are we what do we have my
goodness gremlins wow we have some of
the original starter pack size because
it's very important to note that all of
year one and all of you two and
everything for lego dimensions all works
with that start of class by that we
brought near to the market last year
these things these magical golden tags
are all for a year too and so we've
brought a selection of some of the 16
IPS for you too cuz your twos about
going all those ip's in year one and
then 16 new IPS for year 2 and how whole
array of new 16 is a lot yeah I tried
reeling off early on it was difficult to
remember the more you know you go at
that time hey Powerpuff Girls and you go
Teen Titans go harry potter harry potter
gremlins Goonies yeah i'm gonna get
stuck already and i got about seven good
yeah Oh spa still knows busters yeah but
their eyes where to find them there's so
many it's so epic ultra mom all right up
okay so how do you go about deciding
what you want in the game what little
the kind of licenses and franchises are
gonna work or is it like let's just get
all the things yeah kind of yeah get
also got all of that all the things we
didn't get last time and then let's get
some more I love it it's fantastic okay
I mean I mean I have to hear about your
personal favorites of the new collection
hmm mine's probably mines prob
BJ yeah honest with you could have been
adventure time we love adventure time
something that we really like and he's
got very unique items he's very cool and
he obviously changes and molds and
Whibley yeah all over the place for me
of the ones we have yes his MO is just
so cool but I'm really looking forward
to Goonies yeah and the team in the
office of really looking forward to
making goons because you've got a sloth
minifigure and then you're gonna be able
to play as as chunk and day oh wow and
Andy and all the goonies exploring the
gabby's movie it's gonna be awesome but
this there's so many that are really
cool Harry Potter yeah very close to my
heart yes yes amazing you and I work
have a gonna tucky and I think a little
bit and i'll see your daughter Lily
plays does she not she does dad does
yeah um there what's her favorite well I
think she she she loves Harry Potter
yeah um but obviously she went on the
journey of the two-legged harry potter
games with me so I think she might be
Harry Potter doubt for now oh ok I'm
sure one of those things he listened to
a song too much and then you're gonna
let it lie yeah but come back I think
I've I've ground into her the goonies
and I think she is as excited for the
goonies as I am well would you say yeah
definitely it's great because it's the
kind of license where we can bring the
like our kids into things we grew up
with socialites a big time yeah and so
she liked it the coolers let's face it
it's much cooler she's really excited
because one of the fun pack figures for
adventure time is Marceline yeah I think
she's really excited about game oh yeah
that's super cool yes I make sure you'll
be okay um but yeah there is so much
great stuff coming and obviously all of
these great brands we don't even mention
we've got sonic yeah oh my god coming
yeah like a dimension so you could have
sonic driving around the hog was express
through I don't know the DC hub and yet
ya know that I didn't trust sonic with
the Hogwarts Express is a more than he's
used to going yeah yeah these things are
all incredibly cool and and that's the
great thing about like a dimensions is
anything works with anything there are
no rules you know it's it's your
imagination in in Lego isn't yeah just
just send them
so you guys have got like puzzles to
play through in the game and stuff like
that can you at any point just play with
any character and get through things yes
of course that is the idea at any point
in time you can just jump into the game
with whoever and interact with that
story you want to and there are no rules
that you know the toys obviously we can
redesign the toys also they start off as
one thing and I've an item that may be a
vehicle may turn into a submarine ya
head into a flying creature and later on
in the game and it's all about kids
using their imagination yeah and this
will there is a very big element of like
the hands-on building not like the
in-game building you're actually putting
Lego together right yeah yeah and that's
the cool thing so that like this this
this extra Paul build the starter pack
you get the the blue dimensions portal
we have new packs this year called story
packs mm-hmm and they come with a
character and an item so for example you
know Ghostbusters one comes with the new
ecto-1 yeah Abby wherever she is she's
there mm-hmm as well as that you
actually get a new dressing so this is
here so you can build it and replace the
the one on your gamepad so you can have
your choice basically yeah but as well
you have huge six levels that tell the
entire movie you have the adventure
world as you'd expect but then the new
thing for this year is four player
battle arenas so you can you tell us
about this yeah thank you see this video
this is a brand new mode and you have to
come over and play at some point if I'm
gunshot absolutely and so the idea is
there for player split you can also be
play the single player so it's like a
party game yet many regards and for each
individual park that we release so even
a fun pack you will have a party mode
you can't have one of these battle
arenas each battle arena has four modes
it has captured the flag it's got tagged
not tick vision is the British thing to
tag in America and it's got a mode where
we punch a giant kind of inflatable
around to the storage of those bases
yeah and and we have the new mold
objective mode which gives the players
many little objectives they have to
complete within the time limit and it's
kind of like a Time Trial thing where
everyone kind of grab an objective
points left right and center and we also
got a Brian Blessed doing the voices
from Flash Gordon that's me
okay I'm too excited I think I think we
have some gameplay demo yes we have some
gameplay demo I think we can go through
janna see if we fit okay do it
absolutely yeah pull pull the cable on
the other thing is to make sure it's
placed in properly hmm no I know down
there and do that you can do it yes good
live its life it is that welcome to lie
okay why things like this is what
happened I'm really sorry if anyone saw
my bottom uh-huh unfortunately I think
they did not but there's still time
that's what's going on here I don't know
oh that's okay magical interference yes
I believe well that's what happens well
yeah I mean that's okay because we have
issued layer to talk about let's talk
about what what are we seeing in the
game in regards to not just the
characters but other kinds of mechanics
so we have a new M gameplay mechanics
with the portal yeah just like the fair
season so the story packs will bring in
and you on the one we have is called rip
and the idea with this is that it can't
there are three dimensions that the
player can travel through and the
standard dimension which is the level
air in and two side dimensions yeah I
like clones of that one but with
different technology in them yeah you
can solve puzzles in in one of the
dimensions and then the other one and
then bring the object into the main one
kind of like fringe style yeah and
bringing things all together yeah that's
really cool one of the things I think is
really interesting about lego dimensions
is that i know so many people who are
not parents and don't have kids who just
absolutely adore this game my best
friend is obsessed with this game he's
like crazy about comic books and
everything do you have any theories as
to why that is like is it the licenses
is at the lego name the nostalgia i say
people love the mashup right yeah yeah
who wouldn't want to play mr. t running
around I don't know in the Goonies yeah
in the DeLorean it's yo eats that a that
is the mash up and it appeals to all
ages the eyes are the great thing it's
just everything from adventure time all
the way through back to you know what I
grew up on you know Knight Rider and
everything else yeah Knight Rider that's
another one which is
I writer so what's left I mean you're
adding 16 new IPs what's left on your
wish list you know the IP list was
massive yeah very difficult to even get
down to 16 we could become old forever
right there are so so so many and locked
lots of the star Gibran's lots of new
brands lots of things for the kids lots
of things for the adults and there's
loads and loads and loads of stuff that
we just want to keep adding to and keep
going right yeah definitely yeah lego
dimensions is definitely here to stay
you know we have big noise last year
again this year we've come back bigger
more noise more ip's more game modes yep
no more packs and and we're just looking
forward to just keeping lego dimensions
going do you plan to move on to a sequel
any stagers it's just about like
evolving and adding on to what you have
now to make it greater and greater I
think think now the focus is to get em
more kids in no more kids engaged in
what we're doing that's why we brought
this the new fun packs out which have
ways of opted into the battle arenas you
don't need a new start park every time I
mean the new fun packs can be like
purchase are quite a lot of things like
what twelve dollars or something like
yeah I think even though there's more
content in yeah they're actually going
to be retailing slightly lower this year
yes so people can get in and play a new
and completely new experience without
having to buy a sequel per se right okay
they're big as you can just expand into
it yeah we're going to go what are the
pricing details like for people who
might not be involved at all but really
like the look of it oh well I think I
think no way involved I think fun packs
are like 12 99 yes and then so the next
pack up is 1999 yeah okay level
internship or 19 yeah yeah yeahs impacts
and then the new story packs they've got
the new poll yeah Lego build and the
choice and the huge movie experience
everything else think they're retelling
at 4998 breathing and then the starter
pack I know that that's just come down
in price by Karmin body is in the States
so I don't know those are all like pick
and choose type things right so it's
kind of like do you expect like you know
kids and not kids like my friend like
all of them like all of us exactly
picking up just like these are the
characters I'm really excited about and
want to see it again
be honest we got a lot of collectors
just collect all the sets I don't even
know the startup are they just collect
all the sets hi all the sets you know I
want to do that you have announced some
of these many bit like V and these these
are all unique in year two yeah every
single one of these we've worked really
hard with our IP partners and Lego to
make sure that every single figure the
only place you can buy them is in Lego
dimensions yeah yeah yeah I'll be honest
we probably would never see a gremlins
Lego set no I'm but now like a dimension
so fantastic yeah you you have gizmo and
stripe with the little red car and it
was the other tag I'm Zach I take a
camera oh yeah it's cool amer another
thing excuse most cameras yeah it's
really cool yeah exactly and he's
obviously got the ability to have the
compound bow attended a rambo as well
excellent is why not cuz reason is under
his reason reasons like would you marry
him after midnight as well yeah turns
into an evil gremlin right yes oh yeah
yeah that's a problem oh so you guys
really thought of everything probably i
hope no there's nowhere else to go
thought of everything games about so are
you gonna keep working through the I
palest jerkin like yeah yeah I mean
that's the idea to keep keep bringing
new things two dimensions i think we've
obviously proved from season 1 through 2
season 2 that the idea is to bring new
things new game modes new ip's new
models and we just keep going and
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
right i mean that's the message we're
getting bigger we are getting bigger
that's amazing well I mean obviously
everyone adores it I just yeah I think
you've done such a clever thing like
Lego is just always gonna carry I mean I
played it when I was a kid my you know
parents had like I said yes my kids now
I still crazy about Lego so I think it
just makes sense to bring it to video
games yeah and it's dan sweet that
you've done that and well done and I am
slightly disappointed and upset to say
that we can't get the cave tied my
question but um there are plenty of
videos that you guys can watch about
like your dimensions online
anyone hasn't seen it the trailer for
year two yes it's so epic yes absolutely
check it out annoy these guys on Twitter
I'll answer all your questions yeah um
the thing they're all on Twitter yeah I
know that to ya annoy everyone
everywhere dimensions uh because we
didn't get this gameplay demo but thank
you so much for coming by and bringing
all the toys it's incredibly exciting
and I know alexr and I are excited yeah
we just we just can't wait yep thank you
for coming by have a great rest of shirt
thanks for joining us and we will be
back again shortly with another dip your
eggy tilted gamespot stage brought to
you by airheads bites